bonsoir messieurs et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france plus d'un
milliard de doses de vaccin anti
qu'ovide administrés dans 207 pays
différents le cap a donc été franchi
hier nous approchons des 8 milliards
d'individus sur terre julien a incarné
dit que vous inspire ce chiffre pourquoi
un bateau d'abord il promis dans un
message d'espoir c'est à dire que ce
milliard de vacciner nous montre un
petit peu tout ce que la science peut
apporter à l'humanité est pour le moment
le vaccin est le moyen le plus efficace
qu on a buté contre lacko vide donc un
message d'espoir c'est un message de
sortie de crise dans les mois qui
viennent mais on n'est pas la fin de la
bataille pour vous d'être gombert que ça
montre aussi l'utilité de la vaccination
dans le monde
oui je me semble un grant apport de
l'esprit humain en tous les cas d'avoir
été aussi vite et aussi bien avec des
nouveautés avec on voit déjà un semblant
de re2 bout du tunnel un espèce de
retour à la vie et madame cas ricco
avait déjà dit il ya quelques mois qu'on
allait gagner contre le coc vite qu'on
allait gagner contre les mutants ça
c'est pas encore tout à fait de fait et
contre des virus qu'on connaît même pas
au corps alors peut-être on peut faire
un zoom sur sur lui l'inde 1 parce que
parmi les pays qui ont reçu le plus de
doses de vaccin il alain 238,4 millions
de personnes ont été vaccinées pourtant
on voit que la situation est
particulièrement catastrophique
est ce qu'on doit continuer à avoir
confiance en la vaccination malgré cette
situation pandémique difficile dans le
pays
oui mais je pense qu'on doit on doit
continuer à avoir confiance alors le
risque et ça tout le monde en est bien
conscient c'est que face à une
population qui s'immunise soit de
manière naturelle en étant affectés soit
par la vaccination si on a un taux de
circulation du virus très important on à
risque
on a un risque majeur d'avoir des élus
l'émergence de variants donc ça c'est un
paramètre à prendre en compte et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut lutter sur tous les
aspects la prévention de la coved et pas
que sur la vaccination
oui parce qu'on en a on parle bien sûr
du double en fin de ce double mutants et
pour vous est ce que on doit tout de
même avoir confiance on a l'impression
on se pose la question en tout cas avec
l'arrivée de nouveaux variants est ce
que le la vaccination va quand même
avoir une utilité est ce que ça va être
efficace pour immuniser la population
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord
le continent venir évidemment c'est plus
facile dans des pays comme le nôtre où
on nous promet vers le moal vers le 15
juillet 90% le dose pour les adultes
mais il faut pas oublier que dans cette
lutte contre le coc vides il y a à la
fois le dépistage à la fois le
traitement est à la fois le vaccin
donc après avoir dit beaucoup de bêtises
sur le dépistage beaucoup de bêtises sur
le traitement on arrive maintenant à des
traitements plus pointues dans les
hôpitaux
et ça on peut le transmettre en inde
également par exemple l'homme savoir
dépister avec la biologie et le scanner
des embolies ça sauve des délais
centaines de milliers d'oeuvres et les
protocoles hospitalier qui se sont
améliorées sont transmissibles aussi de
pays à pays avec l'apparition des cônes
les anticoagulants par exemple assez
nécessaire puisqu'on sait aujourd'hui
que les grands dangers de ce virus était
la thrombose et son tropisme basculait
et que comme c'est probablement le
deuxième virus depuis la grippe
espagnole avec ce tropisme vasculaire
bas on sait déjà aujourd'hui que de
toute façon on va avoir des chiffres
heureusement nettement moins la plupart
des pays en développement ont commencé à
injecter le sérum à leur population
mais pour l'organisation mondiale de la
santé la vaccination reste un privilège
des pays développés ce que c'est aussi
ce que vous constatez julien cardy est
ce que vous constatez ce déséquilibre
assez ce qui est un déséquilibré que ce
déséquilibre il va falloir de toute
manière de le corriger
dans les mois et années qui viennent
mais bon je pense qu'il faut il faut
quand même regarder ce qui est en train
de se passer faut pas se tromper
d'ennemi
ça fait un an et demi que l'épidémie est
apparue à ce stade on a vacciné déjà un
milliard de personnes et on peut compter
sur la solidarité internationale
en plus de la science et de tout ce
qu'elle nous apporte pour lutter contre
l'épidémie encore dans les mois et
années qui viennent mais on s'en
débarrassera pas de sitôt et ça on le
sait tous et pour vous un second père
qu'est ce que me dit non oui moi je suis
optimiste je pense que le génie de l'usc
rue main on faisait beaucoup
mais même dans un pays comme israël où
on a été
ils ont été en pointe du traitement on
prévoit évidemment il sera peut-être
nécessaire d'avoir des des vaccinations
supplémentaires d'ici quelques mois
c'est à dire il faut être modérément
optimiste mais je crois qu'on peut
l'être quand même fortement
oui et justement au regard de sa
population c'est d'ailleurs israël qui
arrive en tête des pays qui ont injecté
le plus de 2 avec près de
six israéliens sur 10 complètement
vaccinés israël
on l'a vu aussi la vie est redevenue
presque normale
julien karvelis ça démontre bien que la
campagne de vaccination est en tout cas
cruciale pour s'en sortir tout à fait à
la vaccination la campagne de
vaccination est crucial à moyen terme
après israël va être confronté aussi au
problème du contrôle de ses frontières
derrière et on voit bien que l'émergence
de variants un petit peu partout dans le
monde va nécessiter une coopération
internationale le contrôle des
frontières dans un premier temps mais
pour revenir à une vie normale
et pour se débarrasser définitivement du
virus il va falloir lutter encore tous
ensemble notre président disait qu'on
était en guerre il ya un an je crois
qu'on va l'être pour encore un petit
moment et tous ensemble oui parce que ce
qu'on peut dire aussi c'est qu'avec
l'arrivée et des nouveaux variants le
vaccin n'est visiblement pas la seule
solution pour s'en sortir pour vous
qu'est ce qu'il faut de plus le
confinement déjà c'est une mesure
indispensable également si elle dit oui
l isi julien karvelis ici si vous voulez
il ya beaucoup de mesures sur lesquelles
déjà il faut qu'on il faut qu'on
s'améliore il faut qu'on améliore nos
capacités hospitalières il faut que la
recherche se développe également dans la
recherche de nouveaux traitements des
antiviraux des médicaments aussi plus
anti inflammatoires pour les patients
hospitalisés
tout ça c'est tout ça c'est super
important et après à court terme en
effet on peut discuter sur les mesures
restrictives en place parce que comme je
vous le disais au départ dans le
reportage
si on laisse un taux de circulation
virale très important face à une
population qui est en train de
s'immuniser le risque c'est qu'on voit
des souches résistantes aux vaccins
émerger et ça c'est ce qu'on craint sur
le plan sanitaire aux dalles gombert
pouvons aussi de toute façon le vaccin
n'est pas l'unique solution pour s'en
sortir
non justement il est très important de
savoir que le dp sage le et les
traitements améliorés et les gestes
barrières bien entendu un réel c'est
important est évidemment les contrôles
des frontières mais qu' évidemment plus
on va aller vite dans l'apport des doses
de vaccins dans les différents pays
et moins on aura de demuth ans et plus
et plus on peut être une dernière
question messieurs les restrictions vont
commencer à être levé à la mi mai
rodolphe gombergh est-ce que
vous pensez que ça va nous aider à
sortir de la crise ou au contraire ça
peut être ça peut devenir un problème
je crois qu'il faut quand même terre les
choses
raisonnablement tranquillement
maintenant ça c'est d'autant plus facile
de le dire qu'on sait que les doses de
vaccin arrive puisque ce breton nous a
annoncé vers le 15 juillet que même ma
lame carrico depuis longtemps prévoyez
une fin mais elles étaient peut-être un
peu optimiste cet été voilà je pense que
globalement il faut qu'on reste prudent
même dans les pays très développé et qui
ont les moyens de se défendre
il faut y aller encore tranquillement
la dernière réaction pour vous julien 15
eliès qu'on peut être confiant avec la
levée des restrictions qui va arriver à
l'animé à écouter dans tous les cas on
n'aura pas le choix moi ça me paraît
risqué mais j'ai un point de vue très
sanitaires on va dire moi je travaille
en réanimation donc mon point de vue est
peut-être un petit peu biaisé en tout
cas on a des taux de circulation du
virus qui sont toujours très importants
des taux d'incidence toujours important
donc en réanimation sera pas tranquille
à l'hôpital non plus ici quelques
semaines à quelques mois donc moi ce que
je veux juste dire à la population c'est
que on entendait une petite musique
l'été arrive
les mesures restrictives respectives se
lève attention quand même je suis
complètement d'accord avec mon avec mon
confrère c'est à dire qu'il faut être
prudent
maintenez les gestes barrières et faire
attention à toutes ces interactions
sociales le temps que la vaccination
cours assez de monde merci beaucoup je
viens carvelli je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin à l'unité de soins intensifs de
l'hôpital de la timone à marseille et
merci également à vous rodolphe gombergh
radiologue à paris